que les Britanniques ont appris
à le connaître. Crererere
emmêlée et blagues maladroites,
il arrive à les charmer avec
Boris Johnson était journaliste,
surtout connu pour le to
acerbe de ses chroniques
dans le Daily Telegraph.
allègrement des élites
déconnectées de Lond
est lui-même issu
de la bourgeoisie anglaise.
et étudie à Oxford, aux côtés de
ceux qui devie p p p plus tard
ses collègues au Parlement.
C'est grâce au Brexit que la
carrière politique de Jonananan.
Rapidement, il se positionne
comme une figure de proue
du camp Leave, favorable au
retrait de l'Union eurenenenenee
En 2016, il devient ministre
des Affaires étrangères dans
le gouvernement de Theresa May.
deux ans plus tard, pour
signaler son désaccord
avec le leadership de May.
"Incapable, dit-il,
(applaudissements)
L'année suivante, Jo
est couronné comme nouveau
chef du Parti conservateur.
des élections générales
avec un message
- Let's do this!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Un slogan efficace
qui permet aux tories d'obtenir
leur meilleur résultat électoral
depuis les années erererererereé
au Parlement, Johnson entérine
Avec une super majorité
Mais les célébrations
seront court
Quelques mois plus tard,
Tout au long de la crise
sanitaire, le nenenenement
Johnson multiplie les ratés
et le premier ministre
Mais le succès de la campagne
de vaconononon et la levée
des restrictions sanitaires
lui refont gagner
Johnson est téflon; il semble
et aucune gaffe ne lui colle,
même celles sur sa vie
personnelle tumultueuse.
Du moins, c'était avant la
récente cascade de controverses,
qui aura finalement eu raison
La fin aura été abrupte et peu
cérémonieuse, pour ueeee
qui rêvait pourtant d'être
le Churchill du 21e siècle.
Radio-Canada, Toronto.